[Musik]
Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München zur Verfügung gestellt.
Ähm, ich werde also über den
positiven Begriff der psychischen Gesundheit oder die
positive Vorstellung von psychischer Gesundheit
sprechen. Mir scheint, dass sich die Art und Weise, wie wir
über psychische Gesundheit sprechen, geändert hat
Gerade in den letzten 10 Jahren oder so, wenn
Leute darüber sprechen, dass sie
zuallererst viel mehr über psychische Gesundheit sprechen,
scheint mir, dass meine Schüler
bei der Arbeit sicherlich viel über ihre psychische Gesundheit sprechen,
haben wir Programme für
psychische Gesundheit und Sensibilisierungswochen für psychische Gesundheit  und Monate
sagen meine Freunde viel wahrscheinlicher, als ich mich jemals erinnern kann, dass sie Dinge sagen,
wie „Ich denke, dass ich
wegen meiner psychischen Gesundheit Urlaub brauche, oder dass ich
einen Tag für
psychische Gesundheit freinehme, also wurde über psychische Gesundheit mehr gesprochen
oft, aber auch die Art und Weise, wie darüber gesprochen wird
, hat sich meiner Meinung nach geändert, wenn Menschen
darüber sprechen, geistig gesund zu sein. Jetzt
sprechen sie zunehmend nicht
nur davon, frei von psychischen Erkrankungen zu sein, es ist
nicht so, als ob sie geistig gesund seien
bedeutet nur, nicht an Depressionen zu
leiden, nicht an Angstzuständen oder bipolaren Störungen oder
was auch immer zu leiden, stattdessen wird psychische
Gesundheit als eine Art vernünftigerweise
bestimmter, attraktiver guter Zustand
hingestellt, um die Art von Gedanke zu erreichen, dass es bestimmte Dinge gibt, wenn
Sie geistig gesund sind
die Sie fühlen, und bestimmte
Dinge, die Sie tun können, die wir einigermaßen detailliert beschreiben können.
Wenn Sie sich beispielsweise jemanden vorstellen,
der sich einer guten psychischen Gesundheit erfreut, stellen Sie
sich vielleicht jemanden vor, der sich die
meiste Zeit entspannt fühlt und in der Lage ist,
unter Druck Entscheidungen zu treffen  der
nicht zu viel Stress verspürt
, der positive Beziehungen hat und
sich in ihnen gut verhält, der in der Lage ist
, Pläne zu machen und sie auszuführen und so weiter
und so weiter, also haben wir immer mehr diese
Vorstellung von
geistiger Gesundheit als einem bestimmten
Zustand  Darüber hinaus einfach jetzt frei
von psychischen Erkrankungen zu sein, wenn
psychische Gesundheit in der Welt der öffentlichen
Ordnung und auch in der Art der
populären Öffentlichkeitsarbeit diskutiert wird  Wenn Menschen
in der positiven Psychologieliteratur,
die einige von Ihnen vielleicht kennen und
die sich mit der Förderung der psychischen
Gesundheit und des Wohlbefindens befasst, über Achtsamkeit und Meditation usw. als Dinge sprechen, die zur psychischen Gesundheit beitragen können, sprechen sie viel
über die Art von Dingen  die
zur psychischen Gesundheit beitragen, aber nicht
viel darüber sagen, was psychische Gesundheit
eigentlich ist, und es scheint mir, dass
dies ein Bereich ist, wenn wir über die
positive Konzeption von psychischer Gesundheit nachdenken, in dem
die Praxis der Theorie einen großen Schritt
voraus ist
Wenn Sie sich also die verschiedenen Arten von
Dingen ansehen, die Menschen
in verschiedenen Bereichen und in
verschiedenen Medien und so
weiter darüber sagen, was psychische Gesundheit ist, scheinen mir die Dinge, die sie sagen, Dinge zu sein, die
oft sehr unterschiedlich sind, sehr, sehr vage und
Dies ist ein Problem, denke ich,
erstens, und damit möchte
ich dafür argumentieren oder sagen, dass ich denke, dass vieles,
was darüber gesagt wird, was
zur psychischen Gesundheit beiträgt, dan ist  Sehr oft
sprechen Menschen von einem Zustand
als einem Zustand der psychischen Gesundheit
, um bestimmte politische oder moralische
oder andere Standards
zu verschleiern, die sie unter dem Etikett der psychischen Gesundheit durchzusetzen versuchen,
aber es gibt auch eine ziemlich
verletzliche respektable Linie  des Denkens
, das darauf hindeutet, dass es nur ein großer
Fehler ist, den Geist als
etwas zu betrachten, das gesund sein kann,
die Kategorie der Gesundheit auf den Geist anzuwenden, ist
nach Meinung vieler, wie wir sehen werden, nur ein
Fehler, also denke ich, dass es ein Problem ist, das
wir haben  kein besseres theoretisches
Verständnis von positiver psychischer Gesundheit haben,
und was ich in diesem Vortrag versuchen werde,
ist, einen Weg zu skizzieren, wie
Sie psychische Gesundheit als real
und wichtig betrachten und gleichzeitig einigen Tribut zollen können
von den Bedenken, die ich und die
Leute über die Art des Diskurses
haben, der im Moment um psychische Gesundheit geht
, also bin ich in gewisser Weise auf dem
Weg. Mein Argument ist in diesem
Ausmaß
lustig  Mit dieser Struktur wollte
ich zeigen, dass wir in gewisser Weise
ein Recht auf psychische Gesundheit haben, aber wenn
wir ein Recht auf
psychische Gesundheit haben, muss psychische Gesundheit etwas Besonderes sein
, aber es ist auch ziemlich
plausibel zu denken  dass psychische Gesundheit so etwas ist
, und daher ist es
durchaus plausibel zu glauben, dass wir ein Recht
auf psychische Gesundheit haben, also ist es eine Art
Zirkelschluss, aber hoffentlich auf eine
nette Art von Zirkelschluss, um Sie irgendwie
aufzuwärmen und Ihnen ein Gefühl zu geben
des Territoriums
möchte ich vier verschiedene
Ansichten über psychische Gesundheit durchgehen, drei davon
sind Theorien der psychischen Gesundheit und die
vierte argumentiert, dass wir
jetzt keine Theorie der psychischen Gesundheit haben sollten,
einige davon sind Theorien, die
ausdrücklich besonders verteidigt werden
Teile der Literatur, andere müssen Sie
irgendwie aus der Literatur ziehen, indem Sie
kreativ lesen, was die Leute über psychische Gesundheit gesagt haben,
aber ich
behaupte immer noch, dass sie alle da draußen sind, also
hier die ersten  Das Theorem ist
evolutionärer Funktionalismus und die Ansicht
ist, dass ein gesunder Geist bedeutet,
einen Geist zu haben, der so funktioniert, wie
er ausgewählt wurde, also sind
wir daran gewöhnt zu denken, dass verschiedene
Teile des Körpers eine evolutionäre
Geschichte haben, also gibt es  Ein Grund, warum
wir Augen haben, und der Grund, warum wir
Augen haben, ist, dass Augen einem bestimmten Zweck dienen,
sie tun etwas für uns, und
wenn ein Auge gesund ist, tut es wohl das
, wofür es ausgewählt wurde,
ähnlich für andere Körperteile
und den Vorschlag  Diese Theorie besagt,
dass wir den Geist
auf die gleiche Weise verstehen können, wie der Geist aus
Teilen besteht, und diese Teile sind da, wissen Sie,
weil sie im Laufe der Evolutionsgeschichte ausgewählt wurden,
also könnten wir zum Beispiel
einen Flug oder einen Flugmechanismus haben,
vielleicht das  Ein Teil Ihres Verstandes, warum
existiert es gut, weil es
evolutionär vorteilhaft war,
den Flug- oder Flugmechanismus zu entwickeln, woher wir
wissen, ob es gut funktioniert, hängt davon ab,
ob Sie es wissen  Es neigt dazu, dass wir
im Kampf aufstehen oder weglaufen wollen, und zwar
ungefähr zur richtigen Zeit. Außerdem haben wir
Schlafzyklen, die
eine Art Teil unseres Geistes sind, dass wir uns
manchmal müde fühlen, wenn es gut funktioniert
wenn es uns ungefähr zur
richtigen Zeit müde macht und uns veranlasst, ungefähr
die richtige Menge an Schlaf zu bekommen und so weiter,
haben wir Emotionen,
wir haben die Fähigkeit, Überzeugungen zu bilden, und
all dies, nehme ich an, hatte eine evolutionäre
Geschichte. Ein Vorteil dieser Ansicht und
diese Ansicht ist  sehr populär, fast bis zu dem
Punkt, dass es in einigen
Bereichen der Philosophie der Medizin als selbstverständlich angesehen
wird, ein Vorteil davon ist, dass es der
wahrscheinlich
bekanntesten Ansicht über die Natur der körperlichen
Gesundheit sehr ähnlich ist, nämlich dass es heißt, körperlich
gesund zu sein  Ein Körper, dessen Teile so
funktionieren,
wie sie
funktionieren sollen, ist normalerweise eine
Evolutionsgeschichte, aber es ist keine sehr plausible
Theorie der psychischen Gesundheit  Aus ein paar
Gründen scheint es zunächst
einmal keine Garantie dafür zu geben, dass unser Geist so
ausgewählt wurde, dass er gesund ist. Es gibt keinen
besonderen Grund zu der Annahme, dass es evolutionär bedingt ist,
ruhig und ausgeglichen und klebrig
zu sein, gute Entscheidungen treffen zu können
und entspannt zu sein
Vorteilhaft, dass
wir wahrscheinlich ausgewählt wurden, um wütend zu
sein, schlechte Laune zu haben, um mürrisch zu werden, um
gestresst zu sein, all dies sind Teile des
menschlichen Geistes, die sich genauso entwickelt haben
wie alles andere.
Ich wähle
Leute aus, von denen Sie wissen,
dass sie die ganze Zeit Zen sind, und das andere Problem ist, dass es
eigentlich ziemlich schwierig ist, wie ich es verstehe
, verschiedene Teile des
Geistes so zu isolieren, wie es möglich ist
, verschiedene Teile des Körpers für
Sie zu isolieren  über die
Evolutionsgeschichte des Herzens
viel präziser und verständlicher
sprechen kann als etwa die Aussicht, über
die Evolutionsgeschichte von z  reichlich
ich weiß nicht Überzeugungen über die
Außenwelt oder Schuld oder reizbare Reizbarkeit
All die Dinge, die wir als
Teile des Geistes betrachten, haben keine klare
Entsprechung zu einer bestimmten Kartierung
, die die Teile des Geistes abbildet und
sagt, wo  Sie stammen also aus dem
Projekt, eine evolutionäre Geschichte über
die verschiedenen Teile des Geistes zu erzählen und
diese Geschichte so herauszubringen,
dass wir denken, dass der Geist
für die psychische Gesundheit ausgewählt wurde, scheint sehr, sehr
schwierig und wahrscheinlich
unerreichbar zu sein  Art von Ziel, das ist
seit langem bekannt, und als
Reaktion auf solche Bedenken
gibt es teilweise eine Bewegung, die
ihre Wurzeln in Leuten wie Thomas Sart
und Michele Foucault hat, die sagt, dass es
einfach ein Fehler ist, die
Kategorie Gesundheit anzuwenden  und vielleicht auch die
Kategorien Krankheit und Krankheit und
Unordnung für den Geist, und das grundlegende
Argument ist, dass der Geist nicht
die Art von Funktion hat, die der Körper hat,
er hat es einfach nicht  klar,
wozu Emotionen oder Überzeugungen da sind und so weiter,
und weil es nicht diese Art von
Funktion hat, die naturalistisch
beschrieben werden kann, ist es nur ein Fehler zu sagen,
dass ein Geist etwas ist, das
gesund oder krank sein kann, also Leute darin
Bewegung die Anti-Psychiatrie-Bewegung
sagen uns, dass wir, anstatt über
Krankheiten oder gesunde Köpfe zu sprechen,
entweder über kranke oder gesunde Gehirne sprechen sollten
oder dass wir diese Sprache überhaupt nicht verwenden sollten,
sondern nur über die Dinge sprechen sollten,
die uns wie ein Verstand am Herzen liegen
das glücklich ist oder das gedeiht oder
das mit Problemen konfrontiert ist oder wir sollten Sie
wissen, dass wir einfach eine Art ethische
Sprache verwenden sollten, um die Gesundheit des Geistes zu beschreiben. Die
Sprache ist dem Körper
und dem Gehirn vorbehalten
eine
Art Rückfalloption, wenn wir
wirklich keinen Sinn beim Begriff der psychischen
Gesundheit finden, dann müssen wir vielleicht
auf die Ansicht zurückgreifen, dass das
daran liegt, dass man das einfach nicht gewinnbringend anwenden kann
Kategorie der Gesundheit für den Geist
gibt es eine andere funktionalistische Geschichte
über psychische Gesundheit, die ihre Wurzeln
wohl bei Aristoteles hat, und sicherlich
nehmen die Leute dort Inspiration für
diese Ansicht, und diese ist etwas
schwieriger zu finden, wenn sie ausdrücklich in der
Literatur erwähnt wird, aber ich denke, sie ist da  und
dies ist die Ansicht, dass der Geist
zwar eine Funktion hat, aber seine Funktion
ganz anders ist als die des Körpers. Die
Funktion des Geistes besteht darin, zu denken, und der
Geist ist insofern gesund, als er
gut denkt, also auf dem aristotelischen
Bild der psychischen Gesundheit  ist
etwas, das Aristoteles selbst nie
gesagt hat, aber es wird beschrieben,
es wird von Menschen gesagt, die von
Aristoteles
inspiriert sind
Dinge aus den richtigen Gründen bilden Sie
Überzeugungen basierend auf den Beweisen, die Sie auf eine
Art und Weise handeln, die ich weiß nicht
weise und moralisch und vielleicht ist  schön
und es macht Sinn, also einen gesunden
Geist zu haben bedeutet, die mentalen Dinge zu tun, zu denken, zu
entscheiden und auf eine Weise zu handeln,
die auf Gründe reagiert, und dies ist
in vielerlei Hinsicht eine attraktive Ansicht, aber ich denke,
es hat einen Nachteil, dass es sich
ziemlich schnell herausstellt  in Umlauf gebracht werden, es ist
sehr schwer, irgendetwas sehr
Bestimmtes aus der rationalistischen Sichtweise
der psychischen Gesundheit herauszuholen. Um nur ein
Beispiel zu nennen, eine Frage, die Sie stellen könnten,
wenn Sie über psychische Gesundheit nachdenken,
ist, wie lange es gesund ist,
so nach einem zu trauern  ein geliebter Mensch ist gestorben Sie wissen
vermutlich, dass es vollkommen natürlich und
vollkommen gesund ist, eine Weile traurig zu sein,
aber nicht vollkommen natürlich und gesund
, Jahrzehnte später traurig zu sein Sie wissen, dass Sie immer
noch über den Tod
Ihres geliebten Menschen trauern,
also was zählt als gesund  Periodenabschluss,
und das ist eine Frage
, von der Sie wissen, dass ich offensichtlich eine
wichtige praktische Frage bin und eine
, die konfrontiert wird, wenn Menschen versuchen,
zum Beispiel Depressionen neu zu definieren
Nun, was ist die Antwort aus
rationalistischer Sicht? Es ist gesund,
so lange zu trauern, wie Sie einen guten
Grund zum Trauern haben, aber wie lange habe ich
einen guten Grund, gut zu trauern? Die
Antwort scheint so
lange zu sein, wie Sie jung trauern  guten
Grund haben, für eine bestimmte Zeit zu trauern,
sofern die Trauer über diese
Zeit zu Ihrem Gedeihen
oder Ihrer Tugend beiträgt oder Sie ein
gutes Leben führen oder was auch immer Sie für
Gründe halten, aber das
klingt so  nur eine andere Art zu sagen,
dass man so lange trauern sollte, wie
es gesund ist, zu trauern, und
dann darüber hinwegkommen sollte, das ist ein Beispiel,
und diese Beispiele tauchen immer wieder auf,
in denen sie ein rationalistisches Bild von
psychischer Gesundheit haben
Gesunder Geist ist eine Frage der
richtigen
Antwort auf
die Gründe  Wenn Sie im Internet suchen, werden Sie feststellen, dass
dies die
Definition der Weltgesundheitsorganisation für psychische Gesundheit ist
und in den
Definitionen
der öffentlichen Gesundheitsbehörden überwältigend vertreten ist, und dies
ist die Ansicht, dass psychische Gesundheit
gut ist  - so
sagt die Weltgesundheitsorganisation, dass psychisch
gesund zu sein nicht das ist, wo ich mich nicht an die Worte erinnern werde,
aber einige in der Art
von psychisch gesund sein bedeutet, ein
Leben voller Wohlbefinden zu führen, und das
bedeutet, gesund zu sein  -angepasst,
persönliche Beziehungen zu haben, die dazu
beitragen, dass sich Ihre Gemeinschaft
sicher und geborgen fühlt und
Ihr gesamtes Potenzial ausschöpft, das ist, was es heißt
, gesund zu sein, also entspricht dies in
etwa der philosophischen
Vorstellung von Wohlbefinden, psychische Gesundheit
zu haben, ist nur, Ihre zu haben  Das Leben läuft in
jeder erdenklichen Hinsicht
gut
ns sagt, es stimmt, es
scheint ziemlich offensichtlich zu sein, dass
man trotz perfekter geistiger Gesundheit ein furchtbares Leben in Niedergeschlagenheit und Wohlbefinden führen kann,
also zum Beispiel, wenn alle Familienmitglieder
bei einem Autounfall ums Leben gekommen sind und
man verloren hat  dein Job, aber es ist nicht
deine Schuld und du warst wirklich krank
und du wurdest gerade ins Gefängnis geworfen du
hast kein hohes Maß an Wohlbefinden,
aber du könntest vollkommen geistig
gesund sein du weißt, dass du auf alles reagieren könntest
Es
gibt keine Garantie dafür, dass nur
weil Sie unglücklich sind und nur
weil Sie Pech hatten, Sie
eine schlechte geistige Gesundheit haben, Ihr Problem darin besteht,
dass das Leben Sie wirklich schlecht behandelt hat,
es ist nicht, dass Sie ein Gesundheitsproblem haben
Umgekehrt scheint es möglich zu sein
, dass es Menschen mit sehr
hohem Wohlbefinden, aber sehr schlechter psychischer
Gesundheit gibt, so dass beispielsweise Menschen, die an
einer bipolaren Störung leiden, bei sehr
guter Unterstützung und guten Medikamenten
wirklich ein fantastisches Leben führen können
die nicht schlimmer sind als alles, was Sie oder ich
oder irgendjemand anderes anstreben würden, und dennoch haben
sie keine großartige geistige Gesundheit
, sie haben eine bipolare Störung, und
sie brauchen fortgesetzte Behandlung und
Medikamente, wenn Sie von diesem Fall nicht überzeugt sind
I  Stellen Sie sich vor, jemand
war Alkoholiker, jetzt ist Alkoholismus
eine psychische Erkrankung
, die normalerweise so behandelt wird, dass
jemand ein genesender Alkoholiker sein kann
und weil er ein Alkoholiker ist,
kann er nicht an Orte gehen, an denen
Alkohol vorhanden ist  kann nachts nicht lange
aufbleiben, weil es zu gefährlich
ist die Gefahr eines Rückfalls ist zu groß
sie müssen viel Zeit damit verbringen
, zu den Treffen der Anonymen Alkoholiker zu gehen
und ihren Therapeuten zu sehen und so weiter, aber
Sie könnten in dieser Position sein und so weiter
könnte fantastisch sein, vielleicht
gehst du wirklich gern zu aa-Treffen, und du bekommst ein echtes
Gefühl von Solidarität und Spaß, und vielleicht ist es wirklich gut für dich,
früh ins Bett zu gehen und
Bars fernzubleiben
, du weißt, du s  bleib zu hause und du
schläfst richtig und du erledigst ein bisschen arbeit
Früh aufstehen und Sport treiben
ist bekanntlich ein Weg, um deine Sucht zu bekämpfen, aber
es stellt sich sowieso als sehr angenehm heraus,
das ist keine Garantie,
sondern nur, weil du gegen
eine kämpfst  Wenn Sie ein ernstes psychisches Gesundheitsproblem haben, werden Sie
unglücklich sein, und es ist möglich, ein
hohes Maß an Wohlbefinden und dennoch ein niedriges
Maß an psychischer Gesundheit zu haben, sodass die
Identifizierung von psychischer Gesundheit mit
Wohlbefinden meiner Meinung nach nur dazu dient, Fehler zu bekämpfen,
so denke ich  dass wir eine neue
Theorie der psychischen Gesundheit brauchen, wenn wir
positive psychische Gesundheit als
etwas Reales und
Wertbares behandeln, und indem
ich versuche, diese Theorie aufzustellen, möchte ich damit beginnen
, über die Art der politischen Bedeutung zu sprechen, die
das hat  psychische Gesundheit kann
gehalten werden, das Papier zu halten, wird als Recht
auf psychische Gesundheit bezeichnet, und wenn ich von einem
Recht auf psychische Gesundheit spreche, denke ich an
die folgende Art von Recht, die Art von
Recht, das Sie auf etwas haben, wenn
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit erfordert, dass Sie es
bekommen, also ein Recht der Art, von der ich
spreche, ist ein Recht auf Verteilungsgerechtigkeit.
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit ist das
Thema, wie Ressourcen oder Dinge
innerhalb einer
Gemeinschaft verteilt werden sollten, um Gerechtigkeit für Sie zu erreichen
Sie könnten egalitär sein Sie könnten
denken, dass Verteilungsgerechtigkeit
eine Qualität erfordert Sie könnten utilitaristisch sein Sie
könnten nur denken, dass es so viel
Gutes wie möglich erfordert Sie könnten Ich
weiß nicht Sie haben vielleicht eine Maxim-Min-
Theorie, damit Gerechtigkeit erreicht wird, wenn die
Die Person, die am wenigsten hat, hat so viel wie
möglich, aber was auch immer Ihre Theorie ist
, so kann eine Theorie der Gerechtigkeit aussehen,
und um Ihre
Theorie der Gerechtigkeit zu vervollständigen, müssen Sie eine
Vorstellung davon haben, was wir
versuchen  verteilen oder auf welche Art von
Gut sollten
wir achten, wenn wir versuchen,
unsere Gesellschaft gerecht zu machen, in der Literatur die
Arten von Gütern, die als
wichtig für verteilende j angesehen werden  Denken Sie an
Dinge wie Ernährung, Bildung, Schutz,
Gesundheit, die Idee ist, dass Sie feststellen können,
ob eine Gesellschaft gut ist, indem Sie fragen, wie
viele Menschen eine anständige Bildung erhalten, wie
gesund die Menschen sind, wie viele Menschen
genug zu essen haben, wie viele Menschen
vor den Elementen geschützt sind, wie viele
Menschen haben  Anständige Kleidung, wie viele
Menschen sind in der Lage, solche Dinge zu bearbeiten,
und auf theoretischer Ebene haben
verschiedene Philosophen
verschiedene Arten von Interpretationen
der Art von Gutem angeboten, auf die
wir uns konzentrieren, wenn wir uns auf diese Art von
Dingen konzentrieren, und wenn ich kann  Sagen Sie einfach ein
bisschen darüber, wie die Debatte abläuft, das
könnte hilfreich sein. Sie könnten damit beginnen, dass Sie
denken, dass wir für
eine gerechte Gesellschaft eine
bestimmte Verteilung von Glück oder
Wohlergehen wollen,
also könnten Sie vielleicht sagen, dass Gesellschaften gerecht sind
wenn alle so glücklich wie möglich sind
oder wenn alle gleich glücklich sind oder
wenn die am wenigsten glückliche Person so glücklich
wie möglich ist, aber das ist nicht sehr
plausibel  Nur weil es einfach
nicht so aussieht, als wäre es fast ein bisschen
beängstigend, sich vorzustellen, dass die
Regierung oder der Rest der Gesellschaft sich
für unser Glücksniveau interessieren sollten. Bedeutet
das, dass
wir eine gerechte Gesellschaft brauchen, um eine gerechte Gesellschaft zu erreichen
?  Regierung, die sicherstellt, dass die
Ehen gut laufen oder dass
wir unsere Zeit
lieber mit dem Surfen als mit dem iPhone verbringen, wenn
sich herausstellt, dass das Surfen uns glücklicher macht, also
scheint das Nachdenken über Verteilungsgerechtigkeit etwas zu sein, das sich mit dem Grad des Glücks der Menschen befasst  zuzulassen, dass die
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit
aufdringlicher ist, als wir vielleicht hoffen, und aber das
eigentliche Problem ist, dass unser Glücksniveau oft
wirklich nur von uns abhängt, es ist nicht
das Problem von irgendjemand anderem,
also wenn ich mich in eine Position
bringe, in der es so ist  Ich kann abends einfach nicht glücklich sein,
wenn ich
zu meinem Abendessen kein richtig teures Glas Rotwein trinke, das
bedeutet nicht, dass ihr jetzt alle
eine Pflicht habt  o stellen Sie sicher, dass ich
dieses Glas Rotwein habe, das ist mein Problem,
nicht Ihres,
ebenso wenn ich nur jemand bin, der dazu neigt, sich
zu ärgern, egal wie viel Sie
mir geben, das ist mein Problem, nicht Ihres, es
scheint eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit zu sein  Die
Regierung oder die Gemeinschaft gibt mir
alles, was ich brauche, um glücklich zu sein, also
haben die Leute als Reaktion auf Bedenken wie
diese andere
Denkweisen vorgeschlagen, da sie es die
Metrik oder die Währung der Verteilungsgerechtigkeit nennen.
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit wird
oft als besorgt angesehen  mit der
Verteilung von Fähigkeiten zum Beispiel,
wo der Gedanke ist, dass
man Menschen nicht glücklich machen
muss, sondern ihnen bestimmte Fähigkeiten geben muss,
zum Beispiel die Fähigkeit
, gut ernährt zu sein, die Fähigkeit, sich
um die Fähigkeit zu bewegen  Haben Sie eine gute
Gesundheit Es gibt viele Dinge, die andere
über Primärgüter gesprochen haben, wobei ein
Primärgut etwas ist, das
Ihnen ziemlich nützlich sein wird, unabhängig davon,
welche Art von Leben Sie führen  oose to live
Andere haben darüber gesprochen, Sie kennen
Ressourcen oder Zugang zu Vorteilen oder
andere Arten von Begriffen.
Diese Art von Bedenken
sollen unsere Aufmerksamkeit auf die
Arten von Gütern lenken, die für so
ziemlich jeden wichtig sind und deren
Verteilung ist  teils gesellschaftlich
bedingt, so ist zum Beispiel die
Ernährung so wichtig, wenn wir
über Verteilungsgerechtigkeit nachdenken,
weil es eigentlich egal ist, wie
man lebt, ob
man Surfer oder Philosoph oder Priester
oder so werden möchte  Architekt oder was auch immer Sie
brauchen angemessene Ernährung Sie werden
anständige Nahrung brauchen, auch Nahrung, wie wir sie
kennen, ist etwas, dessen
Verteilung oft von
Mustern der Ausbeutung und Armut und
von Machtstrukturen gesteuert wird, also ob Sie
genug Nahrung haben  normalerweise weißt
du nicht, ob du nicht genug zu essen
hast, es ist normalerweise nicht deine schuld, es spiegelt normalerweise teilweise
wider, wie soziale strukturen menschen verändern  Das Leben von Menschen in Ihrer
Gesellschaft
und das sind Gründe zu der Annahme, dass
zum Beispiel Ernährung und
andere Fähigkeiten und Ressourcen ein
Anliegen der Verteilungsgerechtigkeit sind und
daher etwas, das die Regierung
oder Ihre Gemeinschaft versuchen sollte,
Ihnen so weit wie möglich zu geben  Es gibt einige
andere Komplikationen, die mit der Debatte über Verteilungsgerechtigkeit zu tun haben,
aber
vielleicht überspringe ich sie. Wir
können in der Fragezeit darauf zurückkommen,
wenn Sie möchten. Ich denke, das würde ich
gerne tun, wenn Sie alle finden  Das
Plausible ist zu sagen, dass es
ziemlich einfach zu verstehen macht, warum psychische
Gesundheit als etwas angesehen wird, aber auch
ein Anliegen der Verteilungsgerechtigkeit sein sollte, denn
Ihre psychische
Gesundheit hat die gleiche Wirkung auf
Ihre Fähigkeit, ein gutes Leben zu führen  dass
Sie sich entscheiden, ebenso wie ernährt zu werden
oder gebildet zu werden oder einen Unterschlupf zu haben.
Wenn Sie also zum Beispiel an einer sehr schlechten Impulskontrolle leiden,
dann kann das
etwas sein, das es Ihnen sehr schwer
macht  u ein gutes Leben zu führen, ob das
gute Leben, das du dir wünschst, ein Leben des
Surfens oder Philosophierens oder
Architekt seins oder etwas anderes ist, wenn du
keine engen persönlichen
Beziehungen aufbauen kannst, weil du dann nicht die
psychologischen Ressourcen dafür
hast  Das wird wiederum ein Hindernis für
Ihr Leben sein, ein gutes Leben zu führen, ziemlich
unabhängig davon, welche Art von Leben Sie weiterhin führen
möchten, da wir jetzt wissen, dass
die Folgen der psychischen Gesundheit teilweise
sozial bedingt sind
Kontrolle und schlechte
Konzentrationsgruppen, die
aus anderen Gründen als Presse anerkannt werden, bei denen die
durch Geschlecht oder Sexualität definierten ethnischen Gruppen
vorhersehbar unter einer besseren
psychischen Gesundheit leiden
als andere, so dass eine psychische Gesundheit
eines dieser Dinge zu sein scheint, das
sehr wichtig ist  Menschen ein
menschenwürdiges, autonomes Leben ermöglichen und auch
deren Verteilung teilweise
von der Art der Machtstrukturen bestimmt wird
existiert in einer Gesellschaft auch, meine ich, körperliche
Gesundheit wird oft als eine Art
Paradigma angesehen, um das sich weitgehend egalitäre
Menschen
kümmern, die sich um Verteilungsgerechtigkeit kümmern. Dies ist
eines der Ziele einer Gesellschaft, die darauf abzielt
, Ressourcen gerecht zu verteilen
ein anständiges öffentliches Gesundheitssystem haben
Gesundheitssystem, in dem
niemand an leicht vermeidbaren Krankheiten sterben muss
und so weiter, aber es ist schwer
zu verstehen, warum Sie einen guten Grund haben könnten zu
glauben, dass die körperliche Gesundheit
ein Anliegen der Verteilungsgerechtigkeit sein sollte, wenn die
psychische Gesundheit  ist schließlich nicht, wenn
jemand einen Unfall hat, kann die
posttraumatische Belastungsstörung, die er
erleidet, genauso schwächend und genauso
schmerzhaft sein und genauso lange anhalten wie die
körperlichen Verletzungen, die er erleidet, wenn
wir an die Lebensqualität der Menschen denken und es
dann versuchen  Ihnen bei
psychischen Gesundheitsproblemen
zu helfen, ist genauso wichtig wie der Versuch, ihnen bei körperlichen Gesundheitsproblemen zu helfen. Aus
all
diesen Gründen denke ich, dass es bei
l  Es ist ein Anscheinsbeweis dafür zu denken,
dass wir uns, wenn es um
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit
geht, um den Grad der
psychischen Gesundheit der Menschen kümmern sollten, was bedeutet, dass wir, da
wir über Gerechtigkeit sprechen,
denken sollten, dass es einen Sinn gibt, den die
Menschen haben  Ein Recht auf psychische Gesundheit Wenn
Sie jetzt sagen, dass Sie in diesem Sinne ein Recht auf psychische
Gesundheit haben, bedeutet das nicht, dass
Sie automatisch wissen, dass Sie uns
Rechte verschaffen, wenn Verteilungsgerechtigkeit nicht
die einzigen Anliegen sind, denen Regierungen und
Gemeinschaften Aufmerksamkeit schenken müssen
Vielleicht muss gegen andere Bedenken abgewogen werden,
ob die Regierung in der Lage ist
, Sie mit psychischer Gesundheit zu versorgen,
ob sie die Ressourcen dazu hat, ist
immer eine andere Frage, und wie bei
all diesen anderen Gütern ist psychische
Gesundheit nicht etwas, das man abgeben kann
Es ist nicht wie ein Croissant oder etwas,
was man Ihnen geben kann, sind die Ressourcen
, die Sie brauchen, um eine
gute geistige Gesundheit zu erreichen, und das können
Dinge wie Sie selbst sein  wissen, dass menschenwürdige Arbeitsbedingungen in einer
Stadt leben, die
nicht ständig deprimierend ist,
wenn man sie braucht, und
so weiter, wenn wir darüber sprechen,
Menschen mit psychischer Gesundheit zu versorgen, in diesem
Zusammenhang Menschen, die ein Recht auf psychische
Gesundheit haben, was wir wirklich sind  zu tun bedeutet
, die Grundlage für die
psychische Gesundheit zu schaffen, so dass Menschen, die sich entscheiden
, die ihnen zur Verfügung gestellten Ressourcen nicht zu nutzen
, dies ihr Problem sind,
aber wenn
sie sie nutzen, sollten sie ein gutes Maß an
psychischer Gesundheit haben  Genauso wie Sie,
wenn wir über das Recht auf Ernährung sprechen
, wissen, dass Sie niemanden zum Essen zwingen
können. Sie können ihnen Essen geben, zu dem Sie sie nicht
zwingen können
die es jemandem ermöglichen, jetzt ernährt zu werden,
wenn Sie
meine Behauptung akzeptieren wollen, dass es Grund zu der Annahme gibt
, dass wir ein Recht auf psychische
Gesundheit haben, dann sollten Sie anfangen, sich zu fragen,
was psychische Gesundheit so sein
könnte  Bei Wir haben ein Recht darauf
Ich habe Grund zu der Annahme gegeben, dass wir
wahrscheinlich kein Recht auf Glück
oder Wohlbefinden haben
, also kann psychische Gesundheit nicht
Glück oder Wohlbefinden sein, es muss
etwas anderes sein, oder?  sei, dass wir
ein Recht auf Verteilungsgerechtigkeit haben, Köpfe zu haben
, die das tun, was die Evolution von
ihnen beabsichtigt hat, scheint mir
das ein bisschen ein komisches Ergebnis zu sein, aber
hier ist etwas, von dem wir
möglicherweise ein Recht haben könnten, anzunehmen, dass
wir darüber nachdenken  Der Wert der psychischen
Gesundheit in Analogie zum Wert der
körperlichen Gesundheit Ich sagte, dass die beiden
Dinge in gewisser Weise unterschiedlich sind, aber
hier ist eine Art, in der ich denke, dass
sie ähnlich sind. Körperlich gesund zu sein,
ist wertvoll, weil es Ihnen erlaubt,
viel zu tun  wirklich, wirklich gute Dinge, also zum
Beispiel, wenn Sie körperlich gesund
sind, können Sie effektiver lernen, wenn Sie zum
Beispiel keine Schmerzen haben, nicht
husten und nicht die ganze Zeit müde sind,
weil Sie sich nicht kennen
habe keine Physik  Wenn Sie ein Gesundheitsproblem haben, dann ist es
einfacher, ähnlich zu studieren, wenn Sie reisen möchten,
wenn Sie eine Familie haben möchten, wenn
Sie ausgehen und Kontakte knüpfen möchten, und wenn Sie
großartige Kunst produzieren möchten, was auch immer Sie großartige
Dinge tun möchten, es ist
normalerweise einfacher  tun, wenn Sie
körperlich gesund sind Krankheiten Krankheiten
und Störungen neigen dazu,
diese Art von Aktivitäten im Leben zu behindern
, aber körperlich gesund zu sein
garantiert nicht, dass Sie ein
gutes Leben führen oder etwas Wertvolles tun werden
Sie könnten körperlich gesund sein
und trotzdem den ganzen Tag nur dasitzen und Chips essen,
Sie wissen und fühlen sich elend, dass das durchaus
möglich ist, und körperlich
gesund zu sein, kann Sie tatsächlich auch in die Lage versetzen, viele
dumme Dinge zu tun. Wenn Sie also das
Ziel haben, tue ich es nicht  weißt du, wie du deinen Kopf
500 Mal gegen die Wand schlagen musst, was
etwas Ausdauer und Kraft
erfordert, also wirst du es wahrscheinlich besser schaffen, wenn du
körperlich gesund bist, also scheint es mir,
dass körperliche Gesundheit sehr wertvoll ist,
aber es ist instrumental va  Es ist
wertvoll wegen dessen, was es produzieren kann,
und die Tatsache, dass Sie körperlich
gesund sind, garantiert nicht, dass etwas
Gutes aus Ihrem Leben kommen wird, es macht es
wahrscheinlicher, aber es garantiert es nicht
und es kann Sie tatsächlich dazu befähigen  einige
Dinge zu tun, die nicht sehr wünschenswert sind -
jetzt spielt die psychische Gesundheit meiner Meinung nach
plausibel die gleiche Rolle, wenn Sie sich
in einem Zustand befinden, den wir
intuitiv als einen
Zustand der positiven psychischen Gesundheit erkennen könnten, wenn
Sie ein gutes Niveau davon haben
Konzentration Sie sind im Allgemeinen entspannt
Sie lassen sich nicht stressen Sie
könnten Entscheidungen unter
Druck treffen Sie sind gut darin,
Beziehungen aufzubauen Sie haben eine gute Impulskontrolle
all diese Dinge Sie wissen, dass Sie
ungefähr zu dem Zeitpunkt Emotionen haben, wenn
diese  Emotionen machen Sinn, dann fällt
es Ihnen leichter, Dinge zu tun, wie
großartige Kunst zu studieren und zu produzieren
, Ihren Job zu machen und Verkehr
und all die anderen guten Dinge im Leben zu
haben. Eine schlechte geistige Gesundheit ist oft
etwas als Hindernis erfahren,
das Sie daran hindert, die guten Dinge
zu tun, die Sie gerne tun würden, das Sie
daran hindert, ein guter Freund zu sein, oder es
Sie daran hindert, reisen zu können,
oder es Sie daran hindert
, Pläne zu machen, oder  hindert Sie
daran, all Ihre Energie in die
Dinge zu stecken, die Sie gerne tun, also hat psychische
Gesundheit diesen Wert,
aber genauso wie körperliche
Gesundheit, denke ich, dass Sie wissen, dass es auch mental
gesund sein kann  Es ist viel einfacher
für Sie, dumme Dinge zu tun, wenn Sie
also die Entscheidung getroffen haben,
anstatt mit dem Kopf an einer Mauer zu stehen,
was Sie tun möchten – ich weiß nicht, wie viele
Grashalme auf dem
Fußballfeld zu zählen sind, ist das, was Sie tun möchten  entschieden
, sich wieder dem zu widmen, was
ein gutes Gedächtnis braucht, es braucht viel
Konzentration und Ausdauer, es braucht
echte Belastbarkeit und Entschlossenheit,
man muss geistig ziemlich gesund sein, um das zu
tun, und wenn das dein Ziel im Leben ist
, weißt du es  es wäre vielleicht besser für dich, wenn
du nicht psychisch gesund
wärst, vielleicht wenn dir schnell die Konzentration ausgeht,
dann würdest du aufgeben und losgehen und
etwas Besseres tun, als nur
Grashalme zu zählen, also um noch einmal darauf hinzuweisen
, dass du weißt, dass du es kannst  denk an Menschen
, die gelebt haben, die Dummheiten
mit ihrem Leben gemacht haben,
sich auf lächerliche Projekte eingelassen
und sich völlig unglücklich gemacht haben,
die das nur können, weil
sie so geistig gesund waren, weil sie so viel
Überzeugungskraft und Ausdauer und
Konzentrationsvermögen hatten und  die Fähigkeit
, Pläne zu machen und ihnen zu folgen, durch
die Fähigkeit, andere dazu zu inspirieren,
mitzukommen und so weiter, und so weiter. Aus diesen
Gründen denke ich, dass es unabhängig davon
plausibel ist zu glauben, dass psychische Gesundheit
von instrumentellem Wert ist, es ist etwas
, das das Leben normalerweise viel besser macht, aber
nicht immer und es gibt keine Garantie dafür, dass
es an und für sich geistig gesund ist,
es scheint nicht wertvoll zu sein,
es ist wertvoll für was  Es erlaubt Ihnen,
dies zu tun, und wenn das richtig ist, wird es
ziemlich plausibel zu glauben, dass die psychische
Gesundheit im Leben die Rolle spielt, die
auch Dinge wie Bildung und
Ernährung spielen, und schützt die Art von
Dingen,
die die eigentlichen Anliegen der
Verteilungsgerechtigkeit sind, warum  sollten
Menschen psychische Gesundheit erhalten, denn das ist
etwas, das sie mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit brauchen werden, um ein anständiges
Leben zu führen, wie auch immer sie sich
entscheiden. Deshalb ist es plausibel zu glauben,
dass wir
ein Recht auf psychische Gesundheit haben, aber ich denke, sie bietet es auch  uns
die Gründe für eine Definition von psychischer
Gesundheit, warum sagen wir nicht einfach, dass
psychisch gesund zu sein bedeutet, stabile
mentale Zustände zu haben, die Dispositionen, Emotionen,
Wünsche, Überzeugungen, Gewohnheiten und so weiter haben,
die geeignet sind, eine Vielzahl von
guten Wegen zu machen  Leben zur Verfügung, das ist
meine Behauptung, was psychische Gesundheit ist, machen Sie
die instrumentelle Verbindung zwischen
der Ansicht, gutes Leben und geistig
gesund zu sein
Geistig gesund zu sein bedeutet einfach, die
Art von Geist zu haben, die es wahrscheinlicher macht,
dass Sie Zugang zu einer
Vielzahl von guten Lebensweisen haben werden, jetzt ist
es eine ziemlich vage Definition, und wie
ich sagen werde  Ich denke, es gibt viele
verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie Sie ausgefüllt werden können,
aber das ist
sowieso mein Vorschlag. Um
dieser Vorstellung von psychischer Gesundheit mehr Details hinzuzufügen,
müssen wir etwas darüber sagen,
was es bedeutet, ein anständiges oder gutes Leben zu führen
Leben, also hier ist, was
ich allgemein über die Natur eines guten Lebens sagen kann. Natürlich
ist dies eine äußerst
umstrittene Frage, und die Menschen haben
unterschiedliche Ansichten darüber, was ein gutes menschliches
Leben ausmacht, aber hier sind einige
Dinge, die wir meiner Meinung nach sagen können  Ein gutes menschliches
Leben besteht darin, glücklich zu leben,
ethisch zu leben und mit weitgehend wahren
Überzeugungen zu leben. Wenn Sie also Ihr Leben unglücklich leben, wenn Sie im Leben
unglücklich sind,
kann Ihr Leben wunderbar sein und auf alle
möglichen anderen Arten, aber es ist kein vollständig
gutes Leben  Wenn es ein besseres Leben wäre
, wenn du glücklich bist, wenn du ein
unethisches Leben führst, und du könntest sehr glücklich sein
und
auf andere Weise viel Erfolg haben, aber
insofern du moralisch
lebst, lebst du nicht  gutes Leben, und wenn
Sie ein Leben führen, das völlig verblendet ist, wenn
Sie ein Leben führen, in dem
Sie vollkommen glücklich sind, sich aber in Bezug auf
die Natur der Welt um Sie herum irren, liegt
der Grund, warum Sie glücklich sind, vielleicht darin, dass Sie Sie
denken  Du bist Gott, aber in Wirklichkeit bist du es nicht,
oder vielleicht ist der Grund, warum du glücklich
bist, dass du denkst, dass du in einer wunderbaren
Ehe bist, während dein Partner
dich tatsächlich die ganze Zeit hinter deinem Rücken nur auslacht
, das ist ein weiterer Respekt  was Sie
versäumen können, um ein Leben zu führen, das so
gut ist, wie es innerhalb dieser
Einschränkungen sein könnte. Ich denke, es gibt viele, viele
verschiedene Möglichkeiten, ein gutes Leben zu führen, und
viele davon können wir uns wahrscheinlich nicht einmal
vorstellen, also bin ich mir sicher, dass es welche gibt
Zehntausende von Menschen in Jäger-Sammler-Gesellschaften haben ein vollkommen gutes Leben
Jahren, dass ich mir nicht einmal vorstellen kann,
dass ich sie nicht einmal
als gutes Leben erkennen könnte, aber das sagt etwas
über mich aus, nicht über sie. Welche Art von
gutem Leben wir führen können, wird
teilweise von der menschlichen Natur und teilweise von den
Umständen bestimmt, unter denen wir leben  finden,
so könnte es zum Beispiel sein, dass
man abstrakt ein vollkommen gutes
Leben führen könnte, indem man still dasitzt und
die ganze Zeit über Philosophie nachdenkt und
völlig allein ist, aber wenn man ein Mensch ist,
dann kann man das nicht leben
weil Menschen soziale
Wesen sind, die
uns also nicht zur Verfügung stehen Ein Leben in
völliger Güte, in dem man
sich ganz den Interessen
anderer widmet, mag abstrakt ein gutes
Leben sein, aber es ist kein Leben, das
verfügbar ist  Für einen Menschen wissen Sie, dass die menschliche
Natur es uns einfach nicht erlaubt, die
ganze Zeit zu 100 Prozent wohlwollend zu sein.
Was Ihrer Meinung nach als
gutes menschliches Leben gilt, wird
teilweise davon abhängen, was Sie denken, dass Menschen sind
fähig, welchen Grenzen wir
durch unsere Natur ausgesetzt sind,
und wie ich bereits sagte, welche Arten von Leben ein gutes
Leben Ihnen zur Verfügung stehen, hängt von
Ihren Umständen ab. Sie wissen, dass das gute
Leben eines Wikingers sich sehr
von den Arten des guten Lebens unterscheiden
wird  uns und dem
München des 21. Jahrhunderts zur Verfügung stehen und so weiter, wenn das
alles stimmt, dann sollten wir damit rechnen,
dass die Menschen uneins darüber sind,
was ein gutes Leben ausmacht, wenn sie sich darüber uneinig sind,
was ein moralisches Leben ausmacht, wenn
sie metaphysische Meinungsverschiedenheiten haben, das wissen Sie
Menschen, die denken, dass
es ein fliegendes Spaghettimonster gibt, werden denken
, dass nichts falsch an einem Leben
ist, das dem fliegenden Spaghettimonster gewidmet
ist
die Natur des guten
Lebens Aufgrund ihrer Vorstellungen von der menschlichen
Natur haben wir unterschiedliche Ansichten darüber,
wozu Menschen fähig sind, und auch
basierend auf ihrer Einschätzung der Arten
von Surr  Gründe, in denen wir uns befinden, sollten
sich meiner
Meinung nach
in Ansichten über die Natur der
psychischen Gesundheit widerspiegeln, also zum Beispiel, ob Sie
denken, dass ein monogames Leben die einzige
Art von gutem Leben ist, das Sie leben können
insofern  Wenn es um Sex und Beziehungen
geht, haben Sie eine andere
Ansicht darüber, was als psychische Gesundheit zählt, als
jemand anderes, der denkt,
dass ein monogames Leben nichts Besonderes ist.
Wenn Sie also denken,
dass der Zugang zu einem guten Leben notwendigerweise
den Zugang zu einem monogamen Leben bedeutet
dann werden Sie denken, dass die Art von Geist
, die als gesund gilt,
anders sein wird als die Art von Geist,
die von jemandem
, der solche Skrupel nicht hat, als gesund gelten würde, und ich denke,
dass diese Art von Meinungsverschiedenheiten eine
Tatsache ist  Sie wissen, dass sich in
der Geschichte der Psychiatrie und des
Denkens über psychische Gesundheit viel von der
Debatte über verschiedene Bedingungen widerspiegelt, z. B.
ob Homosexualität oug ist oder nicht  ob [Musik-]Atheismus
als psychische Störung zu zählen ist,
ob
[Musik-]
Atheismus, was als psychische
Störung zu zählen ist, wie es zeitweise der Fall war, und
sicherlich, ob bestimmte Arten von
Verhaltensleidenschaften
als psychische Störungen gezählt werden sollten, also zum Beispiel
Hyperaktivität und Kinder
von einigen Menschen als Zeichen schlechter psychischer
Gesundheit angesehen wird und von anderen als nur
Kinder, die Kinder sind, das sind die Arten von
Meinungsverschiedenheiten, von denen ich denke,
dass sie nach meiner Auffassung von
der Natur der psychischen Gesundheit auftreten sollten, da
es sich im Grunde um Meinungsverschiedenheiten handelt
über die menschliche Natur oder über die Moral oder darüber
oder allgemeiner darüber, was als
gutes menschliches Leben gilt. Insofern gehe ich
davon aus, dass psychische Gesundheit eine Art
moralisches Konzept ist, unter anderem hängt davon ab, was
Sie als psychische Gesundheit betrachten
teils davon, was
man als gute Lebensweise ansieht, und
das ist eine moralische, teils eine moralische Frage,
und daher, ob Sie glauben, dass die Menschen
geistig gerüstet sind, um zu leben  od Leben
wird teilweise von Ihren moralischen Ansichten abhängen,
also sollten wir erwarten, dass Menschen mit
unterschiedlichen moralischen Ansichten stark anderer Meinung sind
über die Natur der psychischen
Gesundheit, wir sollten auch erwarten, dass
Menschen viele, viele Fehler machen, und so wissen wir
, dass im Laufe der Geschichte die Menschheit
verschiedene Menschen gemacht hat  absolut
schreckliche moralische Ansichten vertraten und wahrscheinlich
einige der moralischen Ansichten, die wir jetzt für
schrecklich halten, und weil unsere Vorstellung
von psychischer Gesundheit diese moralischen Ansichten widerspiegelt,
sollten wir sehr vorsichtig und demütig sein, wenn wir
unsere Ansichten
über die Natur der psychischen Gesundheit
anderen aufzwingen  Genauso wie Sie wissen, dass
Homosexuelle lange Zeit schrecklich behandelt
wurden, weil ihre Homosexualität
als Geisteskrankheit ausgelegt wurde, wissen Sie,
dass wir vielleicht feststellen, dass es einige
Dinge gibt, die wir jetzt als psychische Gesundheitsprobleme betrachten
, die wir nur
deshalb als solche betrachten  falsche moralische Ansichten haben, nicht
weil wir
die Wahrheit über die Funktion eines gesunden
Geistes irgendwie durchschauen,
okay so  Das ist so ziemlich meine Ansicht. Ich
möchte zum Schluss nur über ein
paar kleine interessante
Implikationen oder Rätsel sprechen, die sich daraus ergeben
, aber ich werde nicht viel länger auf eine
Frage eingehen, die ich für wichtig halte und die ich
über die Natur der psychischen Gesundheit
stellen möchte  Was in der Literatur viel übersehen wird,
ist die Frage, ob
psychische Gesundheit kulturell oder auf
andere Weise relativ sein könnte.
Einerseits scheint es lächerlich zu glauben, dass dies
der Fall sein könnte, wenn wir über die
Gesundheit des menschlichen
Geistes sprechen  Sicherlich ist ein Mensch, den Sie kennen, ein gesunder
Geist, nur ein gesunder Geist und ein gesundes Auge sind
wichtig, wo oder wann er gefunden wird, aber
andererseits ist es ziemlich einfach, sich
vorzustellen, Sie kennen einen Wikinger, der
für einen Wikinger geistig vollkommen gesund war,
aber zu Recht gesetzt würde  in einer
Institution, wenn sie wie hier und
jetzt existieren, und es scheint mir, dass wir
dies sagen sollten, obwohl es gewisse
Gemeinsamkeiten gibt, die mit der menschlichen
Natur verbunden sind, die für Vorstellungen von
psychischer Gesundheit gelten  Je nach Zeit und
Ort wird sich herausstellen, dass
psychische Gesundheit relativ ist, was
es braucht, um ein psychisch gesunder 25-
Jähriger in Deutschland in einer Stadt zu sein, der sich heute
sehr von dem unterscheiden kann, was es
brauchte, um ein psychisch gesunder 25-Jähriger zu sein
alt in der Savanne vor 30.000
Jahren, also kann es zum Beispiel einen großen Unterschied machen, ob Sie in einer
Gesellschaft der Analphabeten leben
, was es braucht, um
geistig gesund zu sein, jemand, der
weder lesen noch schreiben lernen kann oder
in unserer Gesellschaft echte Schwierigkeiten damit hat  Die Gesellschaft leidet wirklich unter
ihrer Fähigkeit, Zugang zu den
Arten von guten Leben zu erhalten, die
den Menschen hier zur Verfügung stehen, was in
einer vorgebildeten Gesellschaft nicht zutrifft. Das Gleiche
gilt für Dinge wie eine viszerale
Abneigung gegen Konflikte, also habe ich das auf
jeden Fall  Sobald irgendetwas
so aussieht, als könnte es einen Kampf geben, renne ich
einfach weg und verstecke mich und ich könnte niemals ein
Tier mit meinen Händen töten, weil
es Zeit ist, hatte nur diese schreckliche
Abneigung dagegen und fo  Meistens
bedeutet das nicht, dass es mir hier vielleicht sogar hilft,
es hält mich davon ab, in so
viele Kämpfe zu geraten, aber wenn ich Fledermäuse in der
Savanne gehabt hätte, wäre ich ein
schreckliches Mitglied des Stammes gewesen, oder wenn ich das gehabt
hätte  In einer Gesellschaft, in der von dir
erwartet wird, dass du aufstehst und für
dich selbst kämpfst, sonst würdest du unterdrückt werden, würde ich
wahrscheinlich nicht so gut machen, also kann deine
Einstellung, wenn es um Dinge
wie den Umgang mit Konflikten geht, einen
großen Einfluss haben  Unterschied zu den Arten von Leben
, die Ihnen zur Verfügung stehen, wenn Sie in einer
Art von Gesellschaft leben, aber nicht in einer anderen. Ich
denke, wir sollten sagen, dass psychische
Gesundheit kulturell relativ sein kann, und das ist
wohl eine weitere Art, in der
sie sich auf einer ziemlich tiefen Ebene unterscheidet
Von der körperlichen Gesundheit wissen Sie schließlich,
dass Sie meiner Ansicht nach insofern ein geringeres Maß
an psychischer Gesundheit haben, als es
Aspekte Ihres Geistes gibt, die es
Ihnen erschweren, unter
den Bedingungen, in
denen Sie sich befinden, Zugang zu guten Lebensweisen zu finden  aber eins  Was ich
tun muss, ist zu unterscheiden
zwischen den Arten von psychischen Erkrankungen
, die als psychische Gesundheitsprobleme gelten, und
den Arten von psychischen Erkrankungen,
die nicht als Probleme für Sie, sondern als
Probleme für Ihre Gesellschaft gelten, also zum Beispiel,
wenn Sie ein hyperaktives Kind haben  In einem
Klassenzimmer ist eine Möglichkeit, mit diesem
Problem umzugehen, zu sagen, dass wir das Kind gut behandeln müssen.
Das Kind hat ein Gesundheitsproblem.
Wir müssen verhindern, dass das Kind
hyperaktiv wird  die Art und Weise, wie
Kindern beigebracht wird, dass sie nicht
lange Zeit still sitzen müssen,
ähnlich, wenn Sie eine
homosexuelle Person kennen, die in eine
schrecklich homophobe Gesellschaft hineingeboren wurde, kann
dies einen großen Unterschied für Ihre Fähigkeit
machen, ein gutes Leben zu führen  Leben, wenn du
nicht offen mit deiner Sexualität
umgehen kannst, wenn du ständig Angst davor hast,
[Musik] zu sein,
du weißt, dass dir Gewalt angetan wird
, wenn du das Gefühl hast,
nicht die Person sein zu können  Wenn Sie es wirklich offen
sagen, kann dies ein Weg sein, nicht in der Lage zu sein, das Leben zu führen, das Menschen leben können sollten, aber ich möchte nicht sagen, dass dies bedeutet, dass Sie ein psychisches
Gesundheitsproblem haben, was es stattdessen bedeutet  ist,
dass Sie in einer Gesellschaft sind, die sich ändern sollte,
damit eine größere
Vielfalt von Menschen in dieser Gesellschaft gedeihen kann,
also bleibt eine Frage, die offen bleibt,
und ich denke, Sie wissen, wenn ich mich dagegen
verteidigen müsste, würde ich sagen  Ein
Problem für andere Theorien, aber
sicherlich ein Problem für meine, ist diese
Frage, wie wir zwischen
Problemen unterscheiden, die korrekt
als psychische Gesundheitsprobleme
für den Einzelnen konzeptualisiert werden, und Problemen, die
besser als ethische oder
soziale Probleme für die Gemeinschaft konzeptualisiert werden, falls
jemand welche hat  Ideen darüber wäre ich
dankbar, okay, also habe ich mein Bestes getan,
um zu versuchen, die Sicht klar zu machen. Das Argument,
wie ich sagte, ist eine Art Umweg, aber
ich hoffe, erstens gezeigt zu haben, dass
psychische Gesundheit etwas dünn ist  g Das
sollte in Diskussionen über Verteilungsgerechtigkeit eine Rolle spielen,
wenn wir
darüber nachdenken,
wie die Gesellschaft organisiert und Ressourcen verteilt werden sollen, sollte
das Ziel, den Menschen ein angemessenes Maß
an psychischer Gesundheit zu bieten, neben
dem Ziel stehen, ihnen ein angemessenes
Bildungsniveau zu bieten  Ernährung und Unterkunft und
so weiter und zweitens, dass psychische Gesundheit
selbst als eine Art Ressource verstanden werden kann
, um psychische Gesundheit zu
haben, bedeutet, die Art von Geist zu haben, die es Ihnen ermöglicht
, Zugang zu einer Vielzahl
guter menschlicher Leben zu haben, so wie auch immer
Wenn du am Ende entscheidest, dir das Leben zu nehmen, wird
die Tatsache, dass du geistig gesund bist
, es dir leichter machen, erfolgreich zu sein,
und genau da gehe ich hin